Archival voice: Used with no dye or fillers…
[Music]
Narrator: We live in an age of plastics.
From the ocean shore to the Himalayas,
the planet is littered with bags, bottles,
and other objects born from plastic.
At times, it seems plastic trash will
haunt us for centuries, if not millennia.
Yet, not all plastic leftoversare durable—or worthless.
In fact, museum conservators are fishing for ways
to prevent priceless plasticartifacts from breaking down.
Nearly every museum in theworld houses plastic objects:
Vintage phones, Disney films,the first artificial heart—
these and other plastic artifacts
are made ofsynthetic polymers that are vulnerable to decay.
Unstable plastics can be found inthings like early billiard balls,
old Legos,
and foam artmasterpieces from the ‘60s.
Over time, these plastic materials—
and even fairly stable ones like PET,
found in water bottles and food packaging—can degrade,
sometimes oozing outadditives and melting into sludge.
Oxygen, heat, and light areoften implicated in this carnage,
but different plastics respond
differently to such environmental factors.
Because plastics come in so many varieties,
conservators sometimes can’t tell exactly
what materials are in their collections,
which can hinder efforts to preserve artifacts.
Some conservators have used sensory data,
such as the sound, feel, and smell of plastics
to tease out the materials’ identities.
A vinegary scent, for instance,signals cellulose acetate.
Archival voice: Celluloid, oneof the earliest of plastics…
Conservators also have turnedto controlled experiments
to get a grasp on how plastic artifacts degrade.
One study simulated the plasticfabrics in modern raincoats.
You might think that storing them at the coldest
possible temperature would best preserve them.
But these fabrics turned brittle
and werepocked with holes after deep-freeze storage.
Storing them at a milder 4.4 degreesCelsius prevented this problem.
Still, running experiments to help
preserve museum objects can be tricky.
Over the decades, modern plastic manufacturers
have switched up theirrecipes for making polymers.
They now add ingredients such asstabilizers and flame retardants.
Old plastics didn’t contain those ingredients,
so conservators who want to save older polymers
need to make historically accurate versions
to test out their conservation methods.
With this in mind, scientists at the GettyConservation Institute
paged through old trade magazines and dug up
the exactingredients of past plastics recipes.
After mimicking the recipes,
the scientists are now running stresstests
on their new old plastics
with an eye toward artificialaging tests down the line.
Saving plastic artifacts ismore than a matter of nostalgia.
These objects may serve as time capsules
forfuture civilizations to understand our own—
just as stone tools havetaught us about the Stone Age.
Losing these ubiquitous strands of polymers
could mean losing a human era to antiquity.
Archival voice: …are only twoof the many plastics now in...
[TV static, followed by click]
[Music]